in may
2017 you pleaded guilty to stealing more
than two million dollars from investors
and
scheming to defraud as well as this is
from wikipedia yeah they're wrong
well let me just finish reading it and
then you tell me why it's wrong in may
2017 you pleaded guilty to stealing more
than two million dollars from investors
and scheming to defraud as well as
criminal tax fraud charges why is
wikipedia wrong and how dare you
well it's about i mean i did plead
guilty to those things which um
i had to oh i was
i got a jury duty summons and i had to
fill out like what charges i pled guilty
to um and i had to go online and look it
up because i didn't
really remember
which is i thought that was interesting
i had to go look it up but actually let
me finish the time because there's one
more point oh yeah
march 16 2022
bad vegan documentary comes out
where you're interviewed
does they tell the story
some stuff is true sometimes some is not
some is disturbingly misleading as you
said okay timeline over anyway what
what's wrong with the um
how would you elaborate onto the you
pleading guilty for two million dollars
stealing so a lot of people plead guilty
when they're for reasons other than
they're actually guilty
so you know it's
even right now if i knew that i was
gonna have to spend four months or three
and a half
um
at rikers
and i was thinking about this recently
and even if i knew
that i'd be acquitted at the end of a
trial
i very
likely would have just taken the four
months because
um
you know the stress of going through a
trial but in particular be incredibly
stressful not knowing the outcome
um and then money and expense i didn't
have and so
you know people plead guilty all the
time even if they don't think that they
that they should
um
and my situation was so complicated
and hard to understand
that it just was the easier thing to do
but also i just was kind of going on the
advice of lawyers and um
so the the choice just so i understand
was to plead guilty
or to go through a lengthy trial
and that trial
would stretch
a long time and it would be extremely
stressful and extremely expensive
because you have to pay the lawyers
right and i didn't have anything
right
and so a lot of people in that situation
might choose to plead guilty and so that
doesn't necessarily mean
the full heaviness of that statement of
guilt
right and i think people plead guilty
all the time in situations where they're
being threatened with
uh
like a heavy sentence
and they sort of feel like they have no
choice but that's kind of part of
a lot of things that are messed up about
the system overall that didn't
necessarily apply in my case but so
we'll talk about to what degree you're
guilty
and what that even means yeah
yeah
it because it depends on
intention i think
um
yeah yeah but then the word intention
also means a lot of things like the word
love
that's true
um all right so
the restaurant closed the first time
when i was away and told to be
off communication
um
and then i by anthony yes
and then
um he told you not to talk to anybody he
told me not to like open email or look
at my phone or whatever
um and so when i
came back
and
had to get it reopened which seemed like
an unbelievably difficult
task and i was kind of shocked that i
was able to pull it off
um you know i worked incredibly hard to
get it reopened
and
you know
because that placement
meant everything to me and so i just
like i just had to get it reopened are
you surrounded by people that were just
angry at you
at that time not well
just the staff and all that yeah but
most of them came back a lot of them
came back i think what was so
unbelievably painful about that whole
time
um was like not being able to tell
anybody what was really going on and in
a sense not really knowing what was
going on myself but not
being able to like having to pretend all
the time was just
like
so you didn't really tell anybody about
uh anthony about him and what was really
going on in part because i didn't really
understand what was going on
so what i did was i raised money to
reopen the restaurant and i think i
raised something like
eight
maybe like 900 grand
um
and probably 90 of that went to reopen
the restaurant
um and i even made two um
sales tax payments
right before we disappeared
so it just sort of logically seemed
like so i didn't it's not like
all of this money was taken and then he
and i ran off together with a whole
bunch of money
it was like i raised a bunch of money to
reopen the restaurant
you know because i wanted the restaurant
to exist again
and i wanted to you know i wanted to run
it i wanted to reopen the restaurant and
most of that money went to reopen the
restaurant
and then i disappeared
so
um
sort of the the timeline gets a bit
wonky
so it's you know this impression was
created that
we ran off with a whole bunch of money
and we didn't so you know if i wanted
to be a criminal and steal a bunch of
money
why would i have put it all back into
the restaurant and reopened it and then
also made
two ten thousand dollar sales tax
payments that i didn't you know
and i also repaid um
you know ten thousand dollars of another
loan i'm you know i was making
repayments and stuff and then boom i
disappear so is your mind
going through a roller coaster here so
could there been multiple use there so
one one mind
is like i love this restaurant i'm going
to reopen it i'm this
chef business owner
this person and the other the other is a
human that's in this
uh complicated love affair
it was not love affair okay
these are just words how can i okay what
i don't want to uh i say that lightly
uh but also not
because love can make us do
dark things and you can say that's not
love but
okay
the thing that traps us the things that
pulls us in to a connection with another
human being
that's love even when it's abusive and
dark and toxic and all those kinds of
things
in some cases i think like if it's
voluntary but in other cases um somebody
pulls you in
so it's not like you're drawn towards
them they they pull you in so just to
clarify even when it's not physical when
it's when the pull is with words
so it's emotional
yeah
you